welcome back to the centerless everyone
yeah it's good to see you here again how
are you feeling about the tournament
yeah I'm feeling quite good I'm the top
seed by 25 points and I hope to play my
best and win this event do you feel
extra pressure being the youngest and
Grandmaster in the world uh like do you
feel like people are watching you and
expect to perform always you know well
at least like you know top three do you
feel an extra pressure because of that
sure but yeah of course everyone expects
me to perform I don't I usually join the
game and so on I don't really consider
these things okay whatever I can do on
the board I'll do and the rest is the
rest another thing I'd like to mention
is that this tournament
the difference between second and Ninth
or tenth there's there's basically no
difference for me okay all right so I
win this and get in the U.S Championship
or okay everything else is the same I
guess you're quite confident about
winning the events so you're just here
to win yes you're right yes that is
awesome and chess wise where do you see
yourself in 10 years uh you're already
like youngest gym in the world you have
achieved a lot and you have still a lot
to achieve right but how do you see
yourself going
in the next year year and a half I'm
playing to break 2700 trying to become
the youngest 27 the youngest super
Grandmaster in the world that record is
currently held by Wei like 15 years I'm
not sure about the exact thing but it's
like 15 minutes around 15 there yeah so
yeah I'm planning to break there and
after that I'll keep trying to go higher
and higher 10 years maybe candidates
World Championship hopefully that sounds
perfect and I hope you will achieve all
this and could talk is the tournament
thank you thank you
[Music]